this work is able to simulate an
ecosystem with up to 500,000 plants for
500 years buckle up fellow Scholars
because we are going to see simulations
with tipping points deforestation yosity
Valley and the story of shrubs and Pines
yes we are in for a ride with this paper
this simulation goes down to the level
of individual branches awesome and this
can simulate cloud formations too and it
gets better it also simulates how the
ecosystem responds to it dear fellow
Scholars this is two minute papers with
Dr Caro now we know that a good
simulation paper has to be able to give
us interesting insights about the world
around us does this one do that well
look first we see clouds everywhere
above the rainforest now and
unfortunately here comes a little
deforestation note that this is just a
simulation no real trees were harmed at
all and look the clouds disappeared and
when the forest slowly grows
back see the clouds come back too why is
that well because of transpiration this
means that rainforests release water
vapor into the atmosphere the trees
sweat if you will now this Vapor Rises
cools and condenses into clouds as we
have deforested this region we have
disrupted this beautiful dance and thus
no more clouds and this paper can
simulate all of these phenomena love it
now let's have a more drastic experiment
here you see how this virtual ecosystem
reacts to decreasing precipitation in
other words what would happen if there
would be less and less rain things are
going as we expect them to go no
different kinds of species arise that
can thrive in this kind of climate and
wait what what is happening well fellow
schols this is the effect of the Tipping
Point this means that the effect of some
changes is predictable up until a point
and after that unpredictable and often
catastrophic changes happen and these
are often irreversible now a slow
drought commences and look at the
patterns in which this shrub land slowly
recedes why slowly well because they are
really good at adapting to the new
conditions until a point of course
however when we do the same thing faster
rain is gone quicker the patterns are
suddenly clumpier and if we do the slow
drought simulation with pine trees you
remember from a previous episode how
they grow their Roots now these are not
so good at adapting to the new
conditions so even in the case of the
slow drought let's see yes they
disappear in clumps o now I know what
you're looking for how can the pine
trees deal with a fast drought
Unfortunately they do even worse and now
hold on to your papers fellow Scholars
because now we are going to do both and
see what happens add shrubs and pine
trees at the same time this is a
simulation after all we can do whatever
we want here and look at that the two
species cooperate and compete at the
same time forming these beautiful stripe
patterns that would not appear otherwise
so in such a simulation paper we all
always ask this sure looks nice but is
this all for show or is this what would
really happen in reality look at this
here are the real patterns that emerge
in theoretical results in these cases
and here is the simulation wow Feast
Your Eyes Upon This incredible agreement
and it gets even better when leaving
theory behind and comparing to real
photos in real world places wow I am out
of words and we have two more
experiments first is simulating how
microclimates emerge this is a
multispecies simulation where we get
species taking place right at the center
of the formation these folks love a wet
climate but not everyone does the
species like a drier weather now let's
remove both of them this Corridor then
then regrows these species showcasing
the famous Forest Edge effect where
different species carve out their niches
responding to subtle changes in light
and moisture and now if you allow me to
I could not resist this one in the
shadow of yami's majestic Half Dome a
thick forest of Pines Whispers of
Nature's intricate dance as we toy with
the vapor in the air mimicking the
breath of a changing climate the trees
form curious ribbonlike patterns across
the terrain but suspense hangs in the
air this lash Tableau is on barrowed
time as the forest wiers leaving behind
a haunting arid landscape with only the
hardiest of trees clinging to life this
is a beautiful utterly fantastic paper
with lots of gorgeous results make sure
to have a look at the paper in the video
description and if you do you are not
only fulfilling your holy Duty as a good
fellow scholar but you'll get to know
more about how to simulate the classic
water cycle how transpiration takes
place how trees sweat if you will
vegetation modeling soil modeling
weather modeling you name it and now you
know what's coming this is coming this
is a magical paper and only about 400
fellow Scholars seem to have credit
before this video and this is why two
minute papers exist to give a voice to
these researchers and show the world how
amazing these papers are that is my
quest and thank you so much for coming
with me I absolutely love my job doing
this if you enjoy this too consider
subscribing and hitting the Bell icon if
you're looking for inexpensive Cloud
gpus for AI Lambda now offers the best
price in the world for GPU Cloud compute
no commitments or negotiation required
just sign up and launch an instance and
hold on to your papers because with the
Lambda GPU Cloud you can now get on
demand h100 instances and they are one
of the first Cloud providers to offer
publicly available on demand h100 EXs
did I mention they also offer persistent
storage so join researchers at
organizations like apple MIT and ctech
in using Lambda Cloud instances
workstations or servers make sure to go
to lamb.com
slapers to sign up for one of their
amazing GPU instances today